au fond les républiques
sont les seuls
c'est vrai que nous avons besoin d'un
projet un projet sérieux il faut nous
remettre sur nos vraies bases les bases
de la république la république de la
confiance
celle qui est voulu par nicolas sarkozy
confiance en la france confiance aux
français avec nos valeurs les valeurs de
la liberté valeurs de responsabilité
redonner le goût de l'entreprise envie
de faire quelque chose pour la france
avec une république exemplaire moderne
ça va être passionnant
les républicains sont déjà au travail
pour les républicains l'éducation est
une priorité après trois ans de gestion
socialiste
depuis la réforme des rythmes scolaires
jusqu'à aujourd'hui la réforme du
collège il y a beaucoup de choses à
reprend d'abord notre système scolaire
produit beaucoup d'échec scolaire
près de 140 mille jeunes sortent chaque
année du système scolaire sans
qualification et nous avons est bien une
ambition pour les jeunes de notre pays
tout d'abord lutter contre l'échec
scolaire et pour cela se fixer les
priorités
par exemple la maîtrise de la langue
française par exemple la transmission
des savoirs par exemple la promotion du
mérite
la réinstallation de l'autorité du
maître et sans doute aussi faudra-t-il
travailler sur le pilotage est
l'institution éducation nationale en
redonnant aux chefs d'établissement
toute la maîtrise de leurs équipes
éducatives
bref réinstaller l'enjeu éducatif au
coeur du projet des républicains telle
est notre ambition
l'outre-mer est une richesse
extraordinaire pour la france
l'outre-mer ne doit pas être une simple
déclinaison de nos politiques nationales
et c'est pour cela qu'au parti des
républicains
nous avons accordé une place importante
à nos territoires
nos départements nos collectivités il
est temps que nous prenions la mesure de
chacun de nos océans l'océan pacifique
l'océan atlantique et l'océan indien que
chacun avec ses spécificités se retrouve
dans un véritable projet et 6 ans à que
le parti des républicains axera son
programme et son plan pour votre mère
face à la menace terroriste réelle mais
aussi à une violence quotidienne que
subissent nos compatriotes augmentation
des cambriolages augmentation des vols
avec violence nos compatriotes attendent
de la sécurité nos compatriotes veulent
être mieux et plus protégés les
républicains ont le devoir d'une part de
réaffirmer la confiance dans les forces
de sécurité les républicains devront
aussi réfléchir à la coproduction de
sécurité réfléchir comment mieux faire
travailler ensemble les policiers les
gendarmes les policiers municipaux mais
aussi des sociétés de sécurité
en réfléchissant aux missions dire aux
français que demain il y aura encore
plus de policiers encore plus de
gendarmes alors qu'il ya moins d'argent
public est un mensonge
donc le projet proposé par les
républicains sera un projet ambitieux
honnête et authentique parlant de
coproduction de sécurité au service de
compacter un projet se construit pas que
tout seul et la volonté du président des
républicains ne peut à sarkozy
ces deux et c'est une promesse qu'il
tient c'est de redonner la parole aux
adhérents donc nos meilleurs experts en
réalité ce sont nos adhérents en réalité
on prépare quoi évidemment préparer
l'alternance mais l'objectif des
républicains
c'est de mettre sur les rails la france
pour les 50 prochaines années t5 et le
plus importante avec des grands projets
des grands objectifs pour notre
industrie pour notre économie pour notre
société en général il s'agit de ça qu'il
s'agit de la france les grandes
directrice pour remettre le pays en
marche et des républicains eh bien on
est au frais